autrefois symbole de radicalité le
tatouage s'est démocratisé depuis 20 ans
le projet des faits meyrals start up de
new york
rendre le tatouage encore plus
accessible grâce à une version qui se
dissout naturellement entre 9 et 15 mois
après injection
[Musique]
une initiative qui se veut à l'opposé
des tatouages présenté comme semi
permanents et réalisés par des amateurs
et qu'il est souvent des lésions
la petite société n'a d'ailleurs
recruter que des tatoueurs
professionnels
aujourd'hui marie ça dessine une fleur
sur le bras d'une cliente qui fait
confiance à cette encre composé de
polymère biodégradable et élaboré selon
la start up avec des dermatologues
[Musique]